in the last video I talked about the two
campaigns that eventually lead to
Napoleon's downfall one of those was the
Peninsular campaign Peninsular campaign
where Napoleon and the French Empire had
to waste a significant amount of
resources fighting and trying to hold
Spain and the other almost more direct
catalyst for the fall of Napoleon was
his invasion invasion of Russia and
we're going to see in this video why it
was so disastrous for Napoleon this is
easily one of the top five I would say
famous military campaigns in all of
history so let's let's remind ourselves
the relationship between Napoleon and or
between the French Empire and Russia
after the fourth coalition so end of you
might remember the Treaty of Tilsit at
the end of the fourth coalition Treaty
of Tilsit they're friends
Russia was part of the Continental
System which means that they would
boycott or that they would not trade
with Britain or allow Britain to use any
of Russia's ports and Russia was allowed
to do anything that they want with the
Ottoman Empire so everything was good
but then we move forward to 1811 where
in 1811 and Russia starts relaxing the
Continental System Russia relaxes
Continental system essentially meaning
that they started to trade a little bit
with Britain so this are all of a sudden
does this begins to annoy if it angers
Napoleon in order for an embargo in
order for an embargo to work in order
for the Continental system work everyone
on the continent has to not trade with
Britain because if someone trades with
Britain Britain could just trade with
them and then that trade could circulate
through the rest of Europe so in order
for this to work has to be total so this
already annoys Napoleon especially
because he defeated the Russians in in
in in the fourth coalition and the
Treaty of Tilsit he thought he was being
nice to them look just just just don't
do any trade with Great Britain
we're going to be good buddies but then
what really got Napoleon this 1812 he
hears that no that Russia is thinking
about taking taking the French empires
part of Poland or the Duchy of Warsaw
so Russia thinking about about taking
about taking Poland so Napoleon figures
gee were no longer friends
I better attack them preemptively so
against against the advice of a lot of
people about actually invading Russia
Napoleon decides to invade so this
directly leads to Napoleon Napoleon in
fading and his other option obviously
would have been just to defend Poland
from Russia but Napoleon you know he he
just says no look if they're gonna if
they're gonna double-cross me like that
I'm just going to go full tilt and show
them who's boss so he decides to invade
in April of 1812 April of 1812 and
Napoleon's no dummy he realizes that the
Russian winter is really vicious so he
says so look if I start in the late
spring like this and I engage the
Russians and I decisively defeat them
all everything will be said and done and
I'll be Emperor of Russia as well before
before Russia even begins to get cold so
what I'm going to do here to just
understand how devastating this campaign
ends up being to Napoleon I'm going to
use one of the most famous charts in the
history of charts some people consider
this to be the best most well-designed
chart ever and this was this was created
by Charles let me use another color I
keep using this this was created by
Charles Joseph Menard Charles Joseph
Menard you can actually get a bigger
version of this on Wikipedia but that
was too big for my screen so this is a
smaller version but it's a fascinating
chart so what it shows is the size of
Nepal
in army as it invades Russia and the
size of the army is shown by the width
of this brown line right here so when he
starts invading Russia he has 450,000
men 450,000 men if you could read this
number that's what it says and you can
find zoom versions on the web if you
just do a search on this and on the
invasion of Russia you'll find this
chart it's very very famous I more than
even teaching you the history this is
also just a neat chart to look at it
it's something you should be exposed to
at some point but as you can see and
just so you have some scope of what's
going on not only does it show you the
size of his forces it shows the path
that it travels and you can already see
that as the as the forces are traveling
the number of soldiers in the force is
getting smaller and smaller and he keeps
updating the numbers so obviously that
width is smaller than that width but it
looks like it's you know it's less than
half the forces at this point then at
this point and just to understand where
this is going on here is a map of
Eastern a map of Eastern Europe and
Charles Joseph Menards map starts right
around here in Lithuania so this is
where the Napoleon forces were strongest
we're headed 450,000 and it kind of goes
like this this is Moscow right here so
this is this is kind of the endpoint and
if I were to trace if I were to trace
this shape onto here it would look
something like this
it would look I'm just trying to show
the path roughly roughly like this and
then you get to Moscow so that line is
the same thing as that line just so you
have some context within the broader
geography of Europe so it's starting off
in what's roughly the north the the
north will almost exactly the north
eastern border of present-day Poland or
you could say the southwestern border of
what's now Lithuania cross this through
what is now Belarus and then goes on
into Russia now as you can see here I
already pointed out that as he's
traveling as he's travel as the forces
are traveling these 450,000 men horses
and and and armaments and cannons and
everything else is getting thinner and
thinner and what is it's just basic
military logistics you have to keep your
supply routes open you have to keep
leaving men behind you have to keep
leaving men behind to essentially guard
the supply routes so just as the longer
your your campaign the further into
enemy territory you have you have to
keep leaving men behind to guard it and
this whole time Napoleon kept wanting to
engage with the Russians the whole time
that he was the whole time that he was
traveling he kept expecting to engage
the Russians but just as he was about to
engage the Russians the Russians would
back up a little bit and this kept
tapping him there were small skirmishes
so obviously he lost some troops here
there but most of this was just to
maintain the supply line eventually he
is able to have a I guess we could say a
a skirmish or a brief I don't want to
say a skirmish it was actually maybe a
brief battle with the Russians in August
in small tanks and that is let me make
sure I get it right on the map that is
right there but once again Napoleon was
victorious but the Russians retreated it
wasn't a decisive victory over the
Russian army eventually he just keeps
chasing them keeps chasing them until we
get to September 7th 1812
so we are in September of 1812 and now
you can imagine that you know we're kind
of in the fall now and it gets cold
quickly out here in in Russia so already
it's getting to be a kind of precarious
position but Napoleon is confident he's
like you know what if I can decisively
defeat the Russians I can take Moscow
Moscow will have food in it and all will
be send on and that's actually brings up
another point that brings up another
point you might remember when I talked
about the War of the third coalition
that Napoleon and it's in general good
military tactics to invade during the
fall because the fall is the harvest
season that way you don't have to have
as many supplies carried with you you
don't have to guard the supply routes as
carefully because you can just go and
take all of the all of the farmers crops
to feed your troops but what the
Russians did is what they call scorched
earth tactics
scorched scorched earth tactics which
essentially means exactly what it sounds
like as the Russians kept retreating
back as they kept retreating back they
burned everything that could be of
benefit to Napoleon's troops so they
burned all the fields they burned all
the fields as they retreated so the
Napoleon's troops couldn't access the
local resources so they had to keep
having a very I guess you could say a
costly supply chain from where they
started as opposed to just feeding off
of the land and then the Russians just
continued to do this on and on and on
all the way to Moscow all the way to
September 1812 where we have the Battle
of Borodino if I'm saying it correctly
so we have September of 88 een the
Battle of Borodino and at this point
Napoleon only had 135,000 only had 135
thousand of his originally for hunt of
his original 450,000 men the rest had to
be left behind to guard the supply route
or they deserted because they were
getting starting to get hungry or they
were lost just with minor skirmishes
that happened along the entire way and
at the Battle of Borodino the after a
long protracted super bloody battle
super bloody battle in which let me
write these numbers down 44 these are
all estimates 44,000 Russian Russian
casualties mostly death but also wounded
or captured and 35,000 thirty-five
thousand French many historians think
this is the most bloody day of battle up
to this day in history
the French are victorious so we have a
French victory here French victory here
so Napoleon's feeling good about himself
Borodino Borodino is right outside of
Moscow he's like you know what I'm just
going to walk into Moscow they're going
to hand the keys of the city over to me
and then my troops are going to have a
good time in Moscow being able to eat on
all the food that must be there and I
will now be emperor of Russia's
well so about a week later he walks into
Moscow and it's completely deserted
so Moscow Moscow deserted all of the
inhabitants of left and they've taken
all the food with them and then on top
of that Moscow starts burning so Moscow
burns and burns and there's some debate
as to why Moscow burned some historians
believe it's because the Russians
deliberately set fire to the city some
believe that it was just a tinderbox
waiting to burn and that the Napoleon's
true and Napoleon's troops were just a
little irresponsible with where they
built fires it's not clear but needless
to say it made Moscow useless to
Napoleon and this is kind of a major
change you know Napoleon just expected
look if I beat your if I beat your army
decisively like I did at Borodino I won
I take the city now you should you know
you should you should give me food and
shelter and I am you Emperor but the
Russians had something different in mind
they said no you will never take Russia
you can have Moscow you can have a
burned Moscow there's nothing in it and
we'll just like to see you retreat in
the Moscow winter and by Napoleon's own
accounts this is a quote this is a quote
that he gave the most terrible of all my
battles was the one before Moscow the
French showed themselves to be worthy of
victory right this is it Verdi no but
the Russians showed themselves worthy of
being invincible so with no one to
recognize Napoleon or to help him out or
to feed his troops he and he's kind of
in a you know a worthless Moscow he
decides to just to turn around
especially because the Russian winter is
approaching so this on this chart you
could see they went all the way to
Moscow they had 135,000 troops they lose
thirty five thousand of them so you have
a hundred thousand troops coming back
this black line right here this
represents the retreat and then things
start getting cold so it's really
interesting about this this chart that
Minard made is it has a couple things
you show the you see you should see the
route that Napoleon's army took on as it
as it went into Russia then in black
this is it's retreat it gets thinner and
thinner and thinner and you see where
they went and on top of that he
shows the temperature the temperature as
they retreated and this is on something
called a Ramirez scale but you can just
multiply these numbers if you can see
them by 1.25 so you can see that was
already you know is not that bad but
over here we're already below freezing
we're well below freezing over here at
the coldest point if if Menards numbers
are right and I've seen some historians
contest the numbers but it was cold
nonetheless it's negative 37 degrees as
we start approaching into November and
December so Napoleon's forces as before
they had this whole supply chain its
core stirred so there's nothing to eat
there were still had nothing to eat then
it started getting cold and while it was
cold and they were retreating some of
the troops would desert they would be
attacked by peasants they would be
attacked by you know just a little bit a
little bit they'd be attacked by various
Russian forces and then there kind of
the final blow was when they were trying
to cross the Berezina River so this
right here is the Berezina River very
Xena River and you can even see from
from the Norwich chart that the width
was respectable but then after trying to
cross that River it just got decimated
by almost you know they almost half of
the half of the soldiers died or
disappeared and these are depictions
these are paintings these are just
paintings of the retreat of Napoleon's
forces in the winter and this is
actually a painting of of the crossing
crossing of Berezina crossing of the
Berezina River and by the time that the
forces got back at the end of 1812 all
the way over here by Menards map you
only have ten thousand troops of the
original 450 thousand so only one in
forty-five returned the other were
either captured deserted or or just died
so when this happened you could imagine
that what not only did Napoleon lose so
many soldiers also lost on the order of
two hundred thousand horses actually
total casualties for this campaign the
Napoleon's the estimates are about three
hundred thousand French troops the
estimates I saw had about two hundred
thousand Russian troops and just to be
clear
portion of the French troops would died
as they tried to retreat 200,000 Russian
troops and then there's a huge amount of
Russian of Russian civilian casualties
and there are also soldiers from other
countries participating on on well
especially on the French side when all
is said and done estimates are over over
1 million over 1 million dead from the
French invasion but beyond even just the
human casualties Napoleon lost on the
order of 200,000 horses
tens I forgot the exact number but
thousands of cannons so you could
imagine that it was just a huge huge
loss to the French military so by the
time this was done the rest of the
powers of Europe could kind of finally
see Napoleon being weakened he was
already bogged down in the peninsula he
had had this huge defeat as he tried to
invade Russia they finally realized that
he was you know now's the time that they
can form maybe a sixth coalition and
really take Napoleon out